even before the summit has officially
opened heads of state embarked on the
question of Libya during a meeting of
the African Union Peace and Security
Council on Saturday evening president
Mohamed Russia in response to a question
by Al Jazeera
about the possibility of the creation of
an African force for peace in Libya
Congolese president Denis Sassou Nguesso
who chairs the African Union high-level
Committee on Libya said the idea is
being discussed we are waiting for the
deliberation by the AU peace and
security members but personally I
believe whenever Africa speaks in one
voice it always wins better laws and I
think yes the time has come
this Libyan crisis this crisis in the
Sahel which poses a real menace to all
Africa gets the interest of all
countries of the continent and we think
that we will have a response to it the
United Nations secretary-general Antonio
Guterres who is here to attend the
summit said EU representatives will be
integrated within the UN mission in the
Libyan capital as the beginning of a
stronger role for African nations in the
global effort to stabilize the war-torn
country but he made it clear that such
efforts may never work if foreign
interference in Libya continues example
it's evident that the crisis has been
seriously aggravated by the presence of
forces and equipment from many other
countries in clear violation of the
Mandate of the Security Council I think
we have to re-establish the sovereignty
of international law and the conditions
in which the decision of the Security
Council could be implemented what there
is condemnation of countries that still
send weapons and fighters into Libya has
been reiterated by the head of the
Libyan delegation representing the UN
recognized government of national unity
tripoli actually there must be some
sanctions for for-4 countries and also
for for personally i mean it's only if
you start sanctioning them then they
consider that this is forbidden you mean
the countries that send weapons and
support groups can you say can you
elaborate on
because he condemned that and he said it
is a scandal it's not enough to just
open them but you have to put sanctions
the United Arab Emirates Russia and
Egypt are among countries accused of
sponsoring warlord horrific after who's
waging an armed campaign to remove the
internationally recognized government in
Tripoli from power we tried to get a
response from the Egyptian president
Abdel Fattah el-sisi when the pastor's
advice but he refused to stop for
questioning it's now the joint response
of 50-plus African leaders of the world
is waiting for Hamad van al Jazeera it
is about